this is a match i'm playing him again
it seems that there are not so many
people in the three plus two pool but
anyway we got it dirty harry and i've
played this
against him before so
he should be expecting it
but i don't see many people really do a
prep work
against the opening they don't really
believe it's any good and they just play
but this is um it's it's very very much
playable
hmm interesting
it just attacks the pawn so do i don't
have a tactic right
knight takes e4 no that doesn't work
this always has to be considered when
the bishop is unprotected there
knight d4
knight before he might just really take
it
okay i'm covering h5 it's a it's a
simple solution
h4 was also a possibility
it's an intro okay no it's not possible
and i had the idea to just move the
knight
and trade bishop against bishop but now
he's not not down
bloop now this is not possible
difficult language so
um i can castle or king
king to g7 by hand let's do that
rook is not bad on h18 so there's no
bishop h5 coming and so on
this is actually a fairly normalish
position
looks like fairly standard
a fairly standard position out of this
out of this variation
so queen to b6 is interesting queen d6
no it's not really dangerous so i can do
that
i want to go rook d8 knight is seven and
ultimately d5
b3 okay so do we go rook
d8 or knight e7 i don't know
i think 97
just cover that and i'm ready now to
push d5 which he stops
now there are a couple of ideas i can
try knight c64 that's the first idea
can also go here i will start
with that just be annoying against the a
pawn
and also give me open up the possibility
to play b5
which is not yet
a serious idea as he is on that
square and can take it
but knight c64 is definitely an option
yeah that made him pause i mean it's not
a huge idea
to attack the pawn
okay i think he didn't want to do that
like from the get-go he didn't want to
put the queen back to b1 now i'm ready
to
jump into d4 this is the thing they play
c4 to stop
d5 but at the same time they allow me
to plant this knight into the center as
well it's actually with a tempo here on
the
on the bishop okay now
what is king h1 does he want to play
f4 maybe
i wonder how i should handle this this
position looks
already pretty comfortable
f4 i can take and i can put the queen
onto e5 that that's always going to be
okay
this has the idea to reroute the queen
okay so i'm taking it
and now the question is i can put the
queen or two e5 or the knight
okay i think i'll go for the queen
and now what
i'm not sure that b5 accomplishes much
honestly
okay um
okay but i don't really see anything
else
i'm not threatening to take this is the
this is the thing
i wonder if he has an idea
can he somehow break through him
it looks very very safe in my mind
maybe he can okay
now he's on that a lot
and he's on the night oh shoot ah no
he outplayed me from that
comfortable position that is awful
i know i'm losing this game this is a
shame
i was so happy with my position crazy
and i had no problem at all
now i didn't see that idea at all
wow totally totally fell asleep at the
wheel here
just lost here rookie is winning okay
wow that was that was pretty awful
because like here i'm
very comfortable really but maybe knight
c6 is better
knight c6 to e5
[Music]
yeah i don't know i was feeling i was
just feeling too comfortable in that
position i thought
i'm going to be okay anyway
here here is this radical g5
i i considered that actually to simply
stop it um any f4 i mean just stop it
i didn't i didn't consider this to be a
serious issue
but i this rook d7 is already kind of a
it's a little bit slow and
it seems that seems to be okay for white
i mean
okay in the sense of actually being
better for white that's what i'm trying
to say
and and this is indeed not so easy i
mean i i recognize that
while this looks good i can actually
not really make any headway in this
position i cannot do anything
that's interesting
and at the end of the day there's 95 i
can definitely
um defend better that that's absolutely
sure
but i should and it's difficult by now
to reroute the knight on e5 it would
make a lot of sense cover f7
and so on yeah but
okay he did well here this is good
and this is then just losing right
knight f5 was already
killing but i didn't have an idea
that's the thing as i said with this b5
already
i knew that i can never really take
there with any
clear conscience
now that was nicely played f4 is good
that that's just good now
and puts me clearly on the defensive so
it seems that i have to reconsider this
here
and maybe um go for a different approach
g5 definitely was possible
like 94 g5 and also i mean this is clear
i mean i can do this
to make white's
plants a bit more difficult and you have
knight to e5 in that f4 takes structure
this is also something that looks a
little bit better
yeah probably the assessment of the
engine here of
equality is is correct i always tend to
be optimistic
in positions like that because in my
experience
once you have reached this formation
with those two pawns and the bishop only
two
you have pretty reasonable chances with
black to be better in the long run
because of the
really bad bishop here so many endings
for example
will be um pretty good for black but you
have to get there
and well as we saw i got basically
checkmated
um yeah i mean this is fine yeah
it's just probably a roughly equal maybe
this is not
actually such a great idea that knight
d4
looks totally normal but it it could be
that
it's a better way to play to be flexible
and in case of f4
to have knight e5 uh ready yeah
okay that was interesting thanks for
watching